it will wrap up with Carly and Olaf MIT
she will tell us about your dreams may
come true
Thanks so when Beth invited me here I
told him that I don't have anything new
to report on on hypervelocity cones so
you said I should talk about anything I
like so that's what I'm going to do so
I'll talk about these MTP to
distributions this stands for
multivariate total positivity of order 2
and I've come to love these
distributions have been working on them
for a couple of years now with subsets
of different people and so what I want
to do today is tell you a bit about why
I like them so much and also tell you
about how they are actually related to
interesting problems in combinatorics
and algebra and geometry so let me first
define what these distributions actually
are and I'll also make it at some point
there will be one slide where there is -
velocity and that will actually connect
to the previous talk that you just saw
so let me define what these
distributions are so what is an MTP to
distribution so it stands for
multivariate total positivity of order
two as I already said and it's a very
strange definition when you see it the
first time so a distribution with
density function P is MTP - if and only
if for any two points in the sample
space it satisfies these inequalities so
if you take two points the density at x
times the density of Y has to be smaller
or equal to the density but I take two
points right the density at x times the
density sy has to be smaller or equal to
the density at X min Y and the density
attacks max
so in particular if you have seen super
modularity right if this density is
everywhere positive then I can take
logarithms on both sides and then this
is really what you get back is log super
modularity so why would anyone care
about studying distributions that
satisfy the strange constraint here well
so they were introduced and here just a
bit of history why were they introduced
so they were introduced because it is of
interest in in probability theory and in
statistical physics so people were
studying distributions that are
positively associated meaning that you
know if you take any random vector and
you take two non-negative functions then
the covariance is always larger or equal
to zero okay so this is a very hard
constraint to check because I have to
check this for any two non-negative
functions I have to check that the
covariance function is always larger or
equal to zero an MTP two is actually a
stronger constraint so this FK very
well-known fkg inequality implies that
actually MTP two implies positive
Association and mtv2 is easier to check
i mean somewhat easier to check because
i only have to check it for any any
points in the sample space so this was
really the motivation for introducing
MTP to just because it is a stronger
constraint and positive association
sorry is it easier domain has to be the
other man has to be closed under this
coordinate twice exactly yes so you need
a structure and in general I will here
be talking about RM so so this was the
motivation for introducing it so let me
now give you a bit of Intrepid of
intuition for you know what kinds of
distributions are MTP to and what kinds
of properties do these distributions
have so first of all they have some very
nice properties and let me first give
you an example of something that is very
disturbing in data science that can
actually happen and I'm sure you've
already seen this happening it's known
as Simpsons paradox and you know since
MTP two is so nice what what I want to
say is that Simpsons paradox cannot
happen under MTV - okay so what is the
Simpsons paradox it's something really
disturbing it is the property that if
you have two random
in this case you know the sentence that
a murderer gets or and and the skin
color of the murder and if you look at
this representation of the data there
are more white murderers that got the
death penalty and black murders if you
actually just figure out what the
percentages however I can also look at
the data in a different way where I'm
also looking at what the skin color of
the victim is and you'll see that in
both cases it's in fact the case that
the black murders got more death
penalties than the white murders okay so
somehow if I look at this representation
of the data white murderers get more
death penalties and black murderers but
now if I'm actually looking at the skin
color of the victims and in both cases
you'll see the black murders get more
death penalties than white murderers so
somehow when I'm conditioning on a
random variable and this is Simpsons
paradox and I'm conditioning on a random
variable suddenly decide the sign of the
Association can flip what was correlated
before it becomes negatively correlated
afterwards and you know this is both of
them are real representations of the
data right that's just depends on how
you're looking at it you might actually
get two very different conclusions and
so mtv2 is a very strong form of
positive dependence which says that no
matter what you condition on the sign
will always remain the same that's one
of the implications of MTP too which is
a very nice implication and in fact even
more so here are some properties that
are well-known so it is closed under
conditioning and we just saw an example
before ok so sorry so this Simpsons
paradox cannot happen and also does
closed under marginalization so if I
have some empty p2 distribution I can
take a slice through it and it is still
going to be
in addition so it's a strong form of
positive dependence so the covariance is
always positive non negative and in fact
when it's zero it means that they're
already independent so usually it only
goes in one direction actually two
distributions it always goes back so
these are properties that we know hold
for Gaussian distributions because all
these nice properties of gaussians
actually also holds for any mtv2
distribution now of course we can ask
well since these are properties of
gaussians that hold this every Gaussian
distribution mp2 that's not the case
okay so let me just tell you what it
means for a Gaussian to be mtv2 so a
Gaussian distribution is defined by its
covariance matrix or the inverse of the
covariance matrix which I here denote by
K and a Gaussian distribution is MTP -
so it satisfies these you know
constraints P of X times P my smaller
equal to P of X men Y times P of X max Y
if and only if the inverse covariance
matrix is an M matrix so I mean coughs
key matrix so what are these matrices so
they are positive it's a positive
definite matrix where all of the off
diagonal elements are smaller or equal
to zero so that already tells you it's a
super strong constraints right what have
you the last time encountered a positive
definite matrix where all off-diagonal
elements are smaller equal to zero so in
fact if I randomly sample positive
definite matrices our correlation
matrices even night for a 5x5 matrix not
even one in a million will actually
satisfy this constraint so why do I want
you to care about it since you know you
should never be encountering them so
because they actually appear in practice
okay so here I'm showing you the monthly
correlations of global stock markets
which you can actually find just at this
website so this is how the correlation
matrix looks like so it's already nice
at least all of the correlations are
positive and to be to a stronger right I
need to take the inverse and still see
that all of the entries of diagonal are
actually small or equal to zero and in
fact if I just invert the matrix you see
that it is in fact MTP
so just by chance you know that I can
ever find a matrix like this is like
smaller than one in a million but Here I
am giving you an example
and I did not go through a million data
sets to find one of these the question
is why right why do they appear and this
table obviously tells you that some you
know this is an important constraint
because I'll give you now another
example this is just in the Gaussian
setting let me tell you in the discrete
setting so here is again the definition
what does it mean for a discrete
distribution in this case a binary
distribution to be MTP too well so say
three dimensional binary I have to go
through all possible all possible
assignments of 0 0 1 1 0 0 etcetera
right and just check that all of these
constraints here hold so for example I
take here as X 0 0 1 is y 1 1 0 I take
the minimum right gives 0 0 0 I take the
maximum get to 1 1 and so this is how I
just list all of the inequalities in
this case there are only 9 inequalities
that are non-trivial these are exactly
the ones that I listed here I ask you so
this so this is much weaker than total
positivity this is total positivity this
is the definition of total positivity
positivity okay so this is multivariate
totally pause a different so MTP two
stones multivariate totally positive oh
and you are not saying TP 2 so you're
just saying TP yeah TP infinity would be
all miners so these are two by two
miners and why is it 2 by 2 you see it
here right this corresponds through to
my children yeah so this is a special
form and in fact an open problem which
is very much openness how to define MTP
R so we know TP r but there is no such
notion as MTP and that would actually be
very interesting to do because it should
be something on tensors
and so this is really wide open actually
how to define that in a nice way so I'm
just doing empty p2 okay so let me just
give you an example of again a real data
set okay so this is a disease syndrome
and pregnant women here is the
contingency table right the two by two
by two table and you see that if you
just you know check all of these
inequalities they're actually satisfied
so again it shouldn't happen I mean I
definitely didn't look through in this
case now 50 different tables just to
find this example so the question is why
is it the case and why should you care
about this distribution so they appear
all over the place and just to give some
intuition why they actually appear so
one can prove that basically anything
that follows at redistribution is MTP -
okay so what do I mean by a tree and why
the stock market and phylogenetics etc
why do they all fit so stock market data
right you I mean one hits belief that
there is a very strong market variable
which is latent right which really
dictates how the stocks behave and hence
if you know one stock goes up then most
of the stocks go up and then they will
go down they might not go up the same
amount right but they will all be going
up and down together just because
there's this very strong market value
behind it and so that's a latent
variable right which is a tree structure
which will point out to all of your
stocks down
similarly in the example of this disease
syndrome we have one disease that we
cannot measure directly and we're
measuring all of these all of these
symptoms
similarly in final genetics right
obviously it's a tree if I look at
phylogenetic data you'll see MTP two
distributions everywhere we're
interested in expression data there you
know in the cell nucleus genes that are
close together they're all turned off at
the same time or turn down at the same
time and all of these different kinds of
applications will actually get to see
MTP to distribution so the same although
super restrictive constraints right that
does seem imput interesting and from an
applied perspectives to actually take it
into account so now let's go a bit more
into the maps I hope I was able to
convince you that these are interesting
and constraints now let me at least
connect this to the previous talk and
and it will mainly connect in terms of
our open problems that I will get back
to throughout the talk so let's see so
now we saw Gaussian and and binary
distribution so they are just a special
case of exponential distributions okay
so binary and Gaussian can both be
written as an exponential distribution
namely a density function that is of
this form here okay where I have some
exponential of some inner product the
factors are my parameters this is just a
function of the data that we also saw in
the previous talk and this a of vector
here this is known as the log partition
function which you know in the previous
talk we saw different examples right off
in this case hyperbolic polynomials and
I'm just taking the logarithm of these
hyperbolic polynomials which are in fact
these barrier functions of the hyperbola
Sudoku
these are the log partition functions
and both the binary and the Gaussian
case can be written like this in
particular in the Gaussian distribution
so what is this a of feta just make sure
that this is actually a density so that
it integrates to 1 so a your vector so
this will give me a density as long as
this a of feta is actually finite and
that's exactly the integral that was
written down in the previous talk I need
this I need this law partition function
or this this a of feta here to be finite
and the question is you know can I come
up with
or you know this Q of alpha was actually
the measure on this space T of X right
so that this is a well-defined
exponential family meaning that measure
actually has to be positive otherwise it
doesn't give rise to it probability
distribution the previous talk was
really on you know how to define this
measure right on this space over here
which is the dual cone so the image of T
of T or your samples will actually be
matched to the dual cone of C and the
question about the Reese kernel was to
come up with a measure over here so that
this densities actually will and so
that's how we defined hyperbolic
exponential family so these are just
exponential families where you know this
a of theta here is of a particular form
where it's some alpha term times the
logarithm of a hyperbolic of a
hyperbolic polynomial and so now one can
ask so this is just a particular
exponential family right and now you can
ask well for a hyperbolic exponential
family what does it mean to be MTP -
okay and so I'll tell you a general
result for any exponential family what
does it mean to be MTP - and now then
the question is of course the hyperbola
city by you something nice and I don't
know let me just tell you in general
it's actually pretty nice so so let me
take any exponential family and say this
exponential family has a space of
canonical parameters denoted by C okay
and now I want to look at in this
exponential family I want to look at
only at the MTP two ones and I'm asking
how does the space of canonical
parameters look like there it has to be
a subset so the question is how does it
look like and then what is nice is it's
again going to be convex so I know the
space of canonical parameters is always
convex and then exponential family and
in fact if you look at just the MTP two
guys they are given by intersecting your
original space of canonical parameters
with a convex cone and what is this
convex cone oh sorry there is a de
missing here
so this close convex cone I can describe
at this duel very easily okay what is
its dual well it's generated by these
kinds of things like these sufficient
statistics right just to sit inequality
that we already know and I don't
actually have to go over all possible X
and Y's in the sample space because it's
well known that to check locks or super
modularity if you have something log
super modular this is strictly positive
you only have to check it for any two
vectors that defer by most two entries
okay so that's why you actually don't
have to check it for all of them but
just for any two vectors that's the FIR
and just so this is how the space of
canonical parameters looks like and so
now the question is of course can you
undo something nice this is a hyperbola
so if C itself is a hyperbolic code of
hyperbola silicon and now you're
intersecting it with this tool so I
don't have any results about how this
looks like in the hyperbolic setting but
I will tell you about what can be said
about this in the Gaussian setting okay
so when I'm taking this space of
sufficient statistics as we saw in the
previous talk to be the full positive
definite cone and then I'm intersecting
it here with this with a space of
sufficient with this space here that
defines my MTP two cone we already saw
in the gaussian case right we know that
a matrix a Gaussian matrix disposal is
empty P 2 if and only if all off
diagonal elements are smaller or equal
to 0 so this cone here is actually the
non negative worth it so the Gaussian
setting I'm taking this to be the
positive definite cone and this guy here
is actually the non negative the non
positive or all of diagonal elements
have to be smaller
that's how it looks like there but in
general I don't know if one can say
something nice about hyperbolic ok so
what are the questions I want to talk
about and where does geometry come in I
want to talk about two different
questions actually the same question but
in two different settings so I want to
talk about density estimation so it's a
very important problem where you know I
give you some dick samples ok so in this
case in r2 and I want and I don't tell
you from which distribution they were
sampled I want to estimate the
distribution from which they came from
ok so there are two different versions
of this problem so I joined a parametric
setting I tell you for example they come
from an exponential family or I tell you
they came from a Gaussian and what your
job is just to estimate the parameters
of this distribution so in the Gaussian
setting to estimate the covariance
matrix so that's parametric density
estimation so this is usually easier
because it gives rise to a finite
dimensional optimization problem because
I just have to optimize over my
parameter then the harder problem is the
second one which is non parametric
density estimation so I don't tell you a
parametric family I don't want to may be
right if I have financial data I don't
want to I mean that's what led to the
crash and yet right I don't want to
assume that it is Gaussian I want to
allow it to have fatter tails so I don't
want to tell you that and all I'm
telling you is for example well I want
to do parameters I want to do density
estimation under the constraint at its
MTP - ok so that's just a shape
constraint so I want to just give you
know two slides on this setting but
really mainly concentrate on this the
more difficult set just two slides
because this could motivate like what
kinds of results you might be wanting to
get if you do actually this whole story
with exponential families that are
hyperbolic so I'll just tell you what
happens in the Gaussian
so let's look at the Gaussian setting I
need to tell you how do we do density
estimation so in both of them there are
multiple ways of doing it I will do
maximum likelihood estimation so I want
to find the density function and
maximizes the probability of seeing the
data write down the probability of
seeing but they man I just maximize that
here I know it's cows e'en and here I'll
just do the constraints so now I'll show
you just in the Gaussian setting what is
the optimization problem that we're
trying to solve okay so I have some
samples from a Gaussian right and I want
to estimate this covariance matrix Sigma
I'm telling you it's Gaussian I'm giving
you data and now I want to estimate that
Sigma that maximizes the probability of
seeing the data so maximizing the
probability of seeing the data well I
can maximize the logarithm of the
probability of seeing the data and
that's exactly what I wrote down here so
this is the log likelihood function this
is exactly what will happen if you just
you know long everything in and here as
we saw in the last talk right to
sufficient statistics where these x
times X transpose so that's this rank n
matrix where n is the number of samples
so this is the function I'm trying to
optimize subject to the constraint that
it's MTP too so it's a convex constraint
as we saw in general for exponential
families and for gaussians it's just
that you are in this non positive
orphaned right now this is a nice convex
optimization problem I can actually
write down its dual and I just wrote it
down here so this is an optimization
problem over the inverse covariance
matrix this is an optimization problem
over the covariance so now the question
is what can I tell you about it so there
are two things that one wants to do when
one does maximum likelihood estimation
and this in statistics so one what would
be nice is I want to get a model that is
interpretable okay so what one likes is
if I get out something here that is
sparse because then you know if I have
this I can then represent that there's a
network and that's kind of the
interpretation I can just you know and
concentrate on these small on these few
edges
so I would like to have something that
fits the data well but it's sparse so
that I get something interpretable
and at the same time also the setting
that one is usually in this one has a
lot of variables but very few data
points so that means my sample
covariance matrix is of rank n where n
is small but the number of variables so
this is a matrix of size K by K at P by
P P is larger than n so that's often the
setting one is in in different
applications so it would be nice if you
know this problem doesn't blow up if I
have fewer number of samples the number
of variables if I don't have this
constraint then it's easy to see that
this likelihood actually blows up to
infinity as long as you know s the rank
of s is not full okay so if you don't
have these constraints then you know
this is completely ill-posed you know
the MLE so they like the estimator that
you know maximizes this the likelihood
is actually it doesn't exist so this
function just goes off to infinity so
these are two things that I would like
to show under these kinds of constraints
and briefly that's exactly what we get
so I can look at since this I have
strong duality I can look at the KKT
conditions and complementary slackness
you can just write it down it's very
simple and it says that either you know
my Emily of the covariance matrix has to
be given by the entries of the sample
covariance matrix or otherwise I get a 0
so why does this already imply sparsity
well you know we know that under mt p to
the correlations all have to be positive
non-negative so obviously in the sample
covariance matrix i can't have negative
entries so in particular all of the ones
that are negative will already implies
eros and so I will get so this we
already saw right under mt p to the
covariances are all larger or equal to 0
and so that means that actually my
estimator is ladies
so geometrically what is happening why
is it sparse is I have this cold as PDF
PSD comb right
and I'm intersecting it to get the MTP
two matrices I'm intersecting it with a
polyhedral cone which is this non
positive or that and now you're doing
maximum likelihood estimation and
obviously very often you're going to
land on one of these faces which tells
you that you actually get sparsity so it
would be interesting to see you know
what happens if you do something similar
under hyperbola City right it's a more
general class of exponential valleys
okay so this is for sparsity now I also
want to show that you know this
likelihood function is actually
well-behaved even if you have very few
samples that this is actually an
implicit regular Arizer and that's
another you know tells you again that
like something very nice is going on in
terms of algebraic constraints here so
this second this one's already proven in
2015 but this is like a multi-page proof
and I'm going to give you the same proof
just in two lines okay but actually
using some nice you know ultra metric
matrices so ultra metric matrices are
matrices that satisfy this kind of
triangle like constraints and they're
nice so why what are we in fact going to
use is that well if you have an ultra
metric matrix and you have no two rows
that are equal you already know that
it's and its inverse is actually going
to be an M matrix inverse will have all
of the entries all of the off diagonal
elements smaller or equal to zero so how
am I going to prove this result so what
I want to do is I want to show that this
problem here doesn't go off to infinity
if I have here a matrix that is a rank -
okay - are larger so how I'm going to
prove that is I'm just going to give you
a primal and dual feasible point okay if
I have that then nothing bad can happen
right so that's all I'm going to do I'm
actually going to construct for you a
primal and dual feasible point just in
two lines okay and I'm going to do that
by constructing a an ultra metric matrix
because then I know that it's its
inverse is already an n matrix hence it
will satisfy these constraints
so let me just do that in two lines so
I'm going to start with a sample
covariance matrix and I want to
construct to you a dual feasible point
so let me go back I want to construct
the dual feasible point so all entries
have to be large or equal to my sample
covariance matrix and I want that its
inverse is actually an n matrix so
construct an ultra metric where all
entries are large or equal to s hence I
know that the inverse is already going
to be an n matrix and then I'm done so
let me just do that to start with s and
what I'm going to do it's really just
built so as if you were doing clustering
I'm just going to build the tree that
basically fits the data the best so I'm
looking at you know all of these entries
of the correlations as how similar are
two points okay and I just choose the
two biggest entries of my correlation so
these are the most similar points and I
clustered them together okay so I build
a tree I cluster these guys together
then I look at the next similar entries
so that would be this entry here is the
next largest one and now I already
clustered rows 1 and 2 or columns 1 and
2 I will cluster 1 2 and 3 together
okay I'll cluster everything together
and I'll replace it by max similarity
because I need to construct a matrix
that is larger or equal to s and you
just continue like that I choose the
next largest entry which means s I'll
cluster these two guys together and the
next largest entry would be this and
then the similarity becomes just an ax
and that's how I constructed an ultra
metric which is primal and dual feasible
so I know that it's not going to go off
to infinity and I can show if you have
two samples than you know no two rows
will be that's true line proof of like
of this fact which is really nice right
it tells you somehow that the MLE
already exists if I just have two
samples so that's very different than in
this general gaussian case so it's a
really very restrictive family that
really act MTP to access there a nice
regular riser and you know you get nice
and sparsity conditions for free as seen
on the previous
so now the question is of course what
happens under hyperbole is the matrix
that you construct this we have sparsity
there in the inverse no no that's only
at the optimum alright so now I have a
point that is primal infeasible but at
the optimum you're going to go to the
boundary okay so in general here all of
the entries will actually connect okay
so these are the kinds of questions that
we like to answer right so how many
samples do I actually need for at least
the Emily to exist the next question
would be how good is the Emily and then
also you know do you actually get sparse
again what this is for so you have it
these would be kind of nice questions to
answer also for hyperbolic exponential
okay so that was kind of the easier
setting where I want to estimate the
density function given that you know I'm
just assuming it's Gaussian where I'm
assuming it's yes so so it depends right
so if I just take a random one where I
don't assume that mtv2 makes any sense
that in general he'll get super sparse
estimates but even under mtv2 it's
actually very very strong regularizer
so we experimented a bit to it actually
make it less strong so for example you
can make it less strong by just saying
that Sigma UB has to be large or equal
to SUV minus lambda that's how you can
relax and tp2 if you want it to be less
sparse at or you can make its parser if
you want to add a lambda so that's how
you can add it also yeah what's another
coefficient to make the Sportster
listeners but really you know if if my
two matrix is empty P 2 and it doesn't
have any zeros well then the Emily will
be the true matrix so then I'm not going
to add in zeros the zeros just come
because this is such a constrained space
so in general I have noise even if it
isn't if you have noise so these entries
will be just sent it so let me now talk
a bit about the non parametric setting
so what do I want to do so I give you
only the constraint that it's MTP - ok
so why do I need constraints so if I
don't put any constraints on it I want
to produce the density that maximizes
the likelihood of seeing the data well I
just put spikes right I just put spikes
everywhere but that's not very
interesting because that just means I
completely trust the data and I just put
masks on my data points so you have like
some kind of constraint that at least
says well I want to you know spread out
the mass of it right so now
unfortunately so this is then the
problem that I won't want to solve right
so unfortunately it turns out that even
if I have MTP - as a shape constraint
that's not enough to make it not be
spiky okay so if I have here in
particular my samples if I just put you
know mass everywhere here around the
band and this is still going to be able
to beat you but probably still not what
you actually want to get so it's not
strong enough to make it not make it
spiky and you know shape constraint
density estimation is a super active
area right now there are many different
kinds of shape constraints that have
been studied and the most studied one is
this law concave ok this really makes
sure that the density is actually
continuous and so instead of just
looking at MTP - we'll look at MTP 2
plus lock okay so MTP 2 plus now concave
you had to start somewhere
while ah concave well it has been
studied a lot and also there are many
many distributions that satisfy low
concavity right so Gaussian distribution
will fall under a uniform gamma blah
blah blah okay so there are a lot of
examples and so this is where we started
ok so combine MTP - with law concave
just to make sure that it actually
doesn't go off to infinity
so what can we say about the Emily so
what can we say about this function that
maximizes the likelihood of seeing the
data so remember this is the problem I'm
trying to solve this is now an infinite
dimensional optimization problem because
I'm maximizing over all functions that
rmtp to unlock okay how infinite
dimensional not like in the Gaussian
setting where I had certain parameters
that I'm optimizing over so this is now
the problem that I would like to see so
under just low concavity as I said this
has been studied and the very nice
result is known by Kuehl sam Worth and
Stewart which says that the MLE so that
the the estimator maximizes that
likelihood that function is in fact they
tend function so it is a tenth function
where the poles of the tenth are over
your data points so this is a super nice
result right because it tells you that
this infinite dimensional optimization
problem can actually be turned into a
finite dimensional optimization problem
because all I need that I have my data
points and I just have to optimize over
the tentpole Heights at these data
points once I know there is a tenth
function so this kind of and in fact it
also turns out to be a convex
optimization function a convex
optimization problem under low concavity
so this infinite dimensional
optimization problem of maximizing
overall law concave functions was turned
into a finite dimensional and convex
optimization problem where all I'm doing
is just optimizing over these tentpole
Heights because I know where to place
the tent poles memory wherever I have my
data points so now if I have n samples
it's an N dimensional optimization this
is a really nice result yeah it's
exactly just a tenth function over
defined by these Heights ok forget about
this is this is like confusing
yeah okay so now a question is of course
and these are the kinds of questions
that we want to answer is well what
happens if we do it under lock on cavity
and MTP - is it again a tenth function
right and I will introduce another
constraint on the next slide so what is
the shape of it
when does the MLE exist again how many
samples do I need how does it look like
and then of course can we compute the N
values so briefly what is this LLC and
why do I want to introduce it
so LLC is again here is the definition
of MTP - that we already saw many times
now LLC is a stronger form than MTP -
and it's somehow so it's a translation
form of MTP - so not only does this have
to hold but it has to hold for any
points where I can translate my points
by this vector 1 1 1 1 or I can transfer
and I have to also be able to translate
it by all of my y's minus 1 so
particular if I choose alpha equal to 0
I get back this but it has to hold for
any alpha larger or equal to 0 so this
is a much stronger constraint now again
why would anyone care about something
like this and so from a statistical
point of view I care about it because
for example in the Gaussian setting it
means that these distributions are
diagonally dominant so meaning that the
diagonal entries are large enough so
that you know all of the row sums will
become positive and these have been
shown to have a lot of computational
advantages ok so if your Gaussian is
like this you can compute all kinds of
things fast a particular loopy belief
propagation etc you know will do
actually very well and now from a
mathematical point of view why does it
why might it be the good the right kind
of constraint this LLC or does this LLC
constraint here
well because it's somehow it's very
close to concavity right so we're going
to combine this mtv2 or LLC with law
concavity and it turns out that LLC is
in the discrete setting is exactly what
you would define concavity to be so in
the discrete setting this LLC is act
surely local cavity so that makes sense
to actually look at this stronger
constraint as well and I'll be looking
at both but this is just a motivation
for why to also look at this LOC nope
still seems strange why would I care
about it yep so we'll have those same
studies do I have large or equal to know
okay so so first of all the question of
like when does the Emily exist okay so
before we show them the Gaussian setting
that the Emily so this likelihood
doesn't go off to infinity if we have
two samples or more so now a Gaussian
MVP to distribution is certainly a low
concave MTP to distribution right so I
should expect that I need at least two
observations when I don't put you know
the Gaussian constraint on to it because
Gaussian is of course much stronger and
it's very surprising I think that in
fact if I have just mtv2 and LA concave
I need just three samples for the Emily
not to go off to infinity okay so this
family is much less constrained and
assuming that it's Gaussian but actually
it is still very very constrained
because you only need three samples for
not to go off to infinity and in fact
under LLC well this is a much stronger
constraint I just need two samples so
okay so we can prove this result but
unfortunately it doesn't tell us
anything about the shape okay so now
we're still okay so I told you when if
this exists how many samples I need but
now I want to tell you something about
the shape of the Emily in particular is
it still attending functions let's start
with something simple I want to tell you
what the support is at least okay so the
support so I have my samples my points
right so I know on the law of concavity
it has to be convex at least and now
will I have this MTP to constraint right
that the product of these two guys has
to be smaller or equal to the product of
these two guys so definitely I need to
have support here because otherwise this
will be you know smaller than the
product of these two I definitely need
to have support here I need to take some
kind of min max closure so some kind of
min max closure convex hull is what you
would expect and so this is what I
expected it to be right so the support
should be the smallest min max close
sets that contains my samples and of
course their intuitive way or what we
thought was true before parent was
always questioning it but I thought it
was
the beginning was that this is actually
equal to the smallest I'm sorry what am
i doing so yeah okay that you can just
take the okay that I can sorry okay so
this is here is the smallest min max
closed and convex set and here I'm just
taking the min Max closure right so I
have my points I take them in my
exclosure meaning I'm adding these two
points and now the question is of course
can I just take the convex hull of my
min Max closure does that give me the
smallest min Max closed convex set that
contains my points in particular is it
still made max closed right if I take
the convex hull of a mimic the closed
set is it still min max closed well I
already said that you know probably not
so it does hold and r2 and it does hold
in the binary setting but in general
that's not the case and let me show you
an example so here is an example so
these are my four points in r3 okay they
are already min Max clothes because you
know the minimum and the maximum of any
two of these points is just a point
itself so this is already min max close
so I can take the convex hull that gives
me this poly tope here and now I have to
give you two points so that the min Max
closure is actually outside of it and
you can do that so you can take this
point here and one point here on the
diagonal on this line and you'll see
that actually I mean the maximum of
these two is outside of the poly this is
in general not the case that if I just
take the convex hull of a min max close
that it will be min max close itself I
have to add a bit more and this actually
has been studied already in the 1970s
and how you get the min Max that the
smallest min max close convex set is
actually very nice there is a nice a
construction of it so you take the min
Max closure and then you project it onto
any two coordinates then you just take
the cylinder on top of it so you take
all of these cylinders and you just
intersect all of them and that will
actually give you the correct
at least we can compute the support so
this is bigger than just taking the
convex all up and in Mexico sure so this
has been done yep it's not just like
adding like this curved line over this
over this upper facet on your triangle
so in this case it would be exactly this
there's no protection only this in this
case it's the only if you do this
construction so I do the projection into
any two into any to coordinate plates
and I take the cylinder on top of it and
you intersect that this is what you do
taking the cylinders over all the keys
okay so we know the support we still I
haven't told you anything about the
shape so the first question the simpler
question I can ask is well I give you a
tenth function can you check that it is
empty PT so if I just do maximum
likelihood estimation under the law of
concavity I get a tenth function well if
it is mtv2 it is the Emily so can you at
least check for me if the tenth function
is MGP - so how and this is actually
also very nice it's like so all I have
to do is I look at my tenth function and
I look at the subdivision that this can
function induces and all you have to do
is you have to look at the walls in your
subdivision and you just have to check
that there by monotone meaning that you
only have two directions where they
defer and in fact the product is small
or equal to zero so let me just say it
in two dimensions so then the slope has
to be positive okay and dimension - and
otherwise you know you just have two
directions where they can defer and you
know the slope has to be positive there
so this is a very simple way of checking
at least at a tenth function is MTP -
still haven't answered that every MLE is
a tenth function at least if I give you
one you can check give it as MTP - okay
so that's nice job or treater comes up
now let's actually get to the question
that we wanted to write
namely is every Emily Mt
is the dmtp to local cave Emily is that
again a tense function and unfortunately
we don't have a complete answer to it so
what we know is that it is the case and
our - and it is the case in the binary
setting then it is always a tense
function at this tenth function can be
computed again using a convex
optimization problem and that's what we
did here so this is just a law concave
Emily and this is the law of concave and
MTP - Emily and let me talk about this
one afterwards so you see already
something nice so here the data points
were generated according to a Gaussian
distribution so you see very nicely that
you know with less samples or with this
few samples law of concavity doesn't
give you anything that looks like a
Gaussian whereas under mtv2 we already
get something that looks very nice like
a Gaussian distribution right just with
this few sample points and this one here
is the Emily that you get under LLC and
so the nice result about LLC and that's
why I also want to introduce it is under
LLC we actually don't have these
constraints so as long as you have any
rational points the MLE is always the
attenti function ok so there we actually
do have I mean we don't have it in RM
but you know for all computational
purposes the rationals are more than
enough right there actually we can show
that this is a tenth function and I do
want to tell you like what is actually
missing why do we not have to complete
our result
okay so the complete result so what this
actually is based on is that in r2 and
in the binary setting and for LLC and in
the rational setting in order to check
that a tenth function is MTP - all I
have to check is that their heights at
the tent poles are MTP - okay so if I
have here a tent function right and I
have some height then if I just check
that these for height satisfy MTP - at
these discrete points that that already
implies that the whole tent function is
MTP - right so I need it to be able to
be true on the whole convex all of these
points so that only holds under in the
binary setting or an R - or for LLC it
holds for any rational points so it is
really and we know that it's not the
case in general
in general it's not the case if you're
on our three for example that I can just
check at the tentpole Heights whether
the function is MTP to there and then
just say that the whole tenth function
is MTP
so that's really what is missing in
particular if I go back to this little
example and this one here right so the
problem is that you know particular over
all of these points right every one of
them will be one of the maxima or minima
any tenth function is MTP two because
the minimum went the maximum is just
that it's just I'm actually happening at
one of these points but so all the
points every time function is MTP too
but of course not every tenth function
over this whole continues polytope is an
effete so that's really what is missing
okay so we need to be able to figure out
where do we have to add in tent poles so
that when you also check it there then
that's enough then that will actually
give rise to the 2d Emily
if you can so we don't even know if
there's a tenth function right so if
it's not the tenth function that it
means that I have to add in like an
infinite amount of tentpoles
for it to be to check if it is empty p2
or not so that's exactly I think the
question also like another question is
where you're going there is like how
many points do I have to add in right so
even when we know there is a tenth
function I think here derp is abound and
here we don't know basically so we have
a way of adding in but probably we're
adding in part too many in general yeah
so we don't know like what are the
balance there okay so let me end it so
okay so this conjecture is still open of
actually showing that in general the
mtv2 emily is always the exponential of
a tenth function for LLC we know it and
this is kind of nice so we have an
algorithm which you know if it outputs
if it outputs something that is MTB - we
know it is V Emily but the conjecture
says it should always be MTP - but it
might not right but then what is nice is
at least if this conjecture is not true
then we still have a way of giving you
an MTP - function namely just I do it
under LLC now then might not be the Emma
D Emily right but at least I can give
you an estimator that is MTP - it's just
a more restrictive constraint and I hope
I was able to convince you that you know
these these total positivity or these
MTP - distributions they really appear
in many different settings where they
are of interest to look at in particular
in finance and biology etc and they lead
to a really nice properties in the high
dimensional setting very few samples and
since it's so constrained it actually
already gives you very nice kinds of for
example density estimates are very nice
parameter estimates etc ok so here are
some references
so in particular one paper will appear
today on the archive this is the paper
where I had at the beginning where you
know any MTP - exponential family is
convex and in particular we're here
looking at the binary distributions and
what it means
thank you very much you saw time for
questions and comments in the case like
suppose you know that a TP 2 ml e is
exponential of a tan function for like
real points right and you know that if
the space of such dense functions like
the heights of hours a pulse still
convex exactly so in this case we know
that this is a convex optimization so
just checking yeah so just putting on
the constraints that at particular
points the temples are MTP do-dads
contracts and that's why we can also
solve it another open problem is
actually to come up with fast algorithms
for doing this ok so just under lock on
cavity that have been like a series of
papers now in in computer science on the
theoretical side which actually came up
with faster and faster algorithms for
doing this under MTP - we don't have
just yeah I think so
in classical science England people like
doing nonparametric regression and you
only control the risk by alchemy I like
the red marker or go to a complexity of
the function classes do have some nice
yeah yeah so yeah so there are a lot of
open problems unlike even how large is
this class right so yeah so we don't
know and in particularly I mean the
conjecture would be that actually this
class that you should be able to get
rates that are very close to parametric
that's so constrained that that's that's
what we're hoping to prove yeah because
this is what it seems like right when
you saw like how much down the number of
samples goes it goes from like P plus 1
to actually two to three so that hints
at the fact that it could be close to
parametric rates yeah that would be very
nice to show so that's an a big open
problem nonparametric statistics right
just how can you get shape constraints
that actually get you down to the
parametric rates this is one contender
yes just a very simple kind of
observation that either form in which
you're looking to save and maximize
something was always logged at plus
maybe the modification the vlog dentist
race log so would that help sometimes
maybe if you are looking in them you
know you can rewrite the logarithm of
your matrix you know if you have a
certain form there which might make it
easier for you to look yeah I don't know
it's certainly not in the nonparametric
setting so before maybe if you have a
hypervelocity cone and you're doing it
in the so here in this setting if you
have a problem over a hypervelocity cone
and you have like some functions there
but then they're not determinantal
anymore so yeah so I don't know what
kinds of tricks can be done there just
to read parametrizations you you might
try to it yeah yeah it could be could be
in particular the hyperbolic ball
exciting might be interesting
others
well then thanks Caroline thinks all
into again tomorrow morning the first
lectures at nine o'clock nine eight